we didn't really have any fast attackers
from texas until he came along
like i couldn't really believe my eyes
like i was in shock his hands like they
were always moving and it was like there
was no like thinking about where to put
it it was just like a non-stop just like
he's off the charts he's like as fast as
a lightning bolt
[Music]
my name is trey griffith and i am the
fastest cup sector in the state of texas
my goal is to be the fastest cup sucker
in the whole entire world
when i first saw trey
begin cup stacking
i was thrilled
kids on the spectrum are always very
passionate and very intense on what
their fixation is
and he just shined i mean you could see
that he was in his element he was
comfortable
he was alive and
he was just doing his thing
trey took it to a completely different
level he was doing it systematically
instead of just kind of for fun and it
was all about getting that next best
time
what trey does in five or six seconds
takes me 10 or 12 13 seconds
we've learned not to
ever discount what he says he's gonna do
sport stacking
is
using a set of
12 plastic cups and you stack them in a
very specific sequence of pyramids
and you are racing yourself and you're
racing a time room
it's a sport that you don't have to be
tall you don't have to necessarily be
able to run quickly as long as you've
got the 12 cups you've got a mat and
you've got a timer you can stack
to me
it's just mind-boggling to see these
stackers like trey and his friends and
you can tell they're not even looking at
the cups that they're stacking it is all
muscle memory i mean it's so fast when
they get to this level that
the naked eye cannot see it all
[Music]
when i found out that i was having a boy
of course i thought about
when i was a boy and playing catch with
my dad in the backyard and you flash
forward
you know thinking about those types of
things with your kiddo
but when trey
found stacking it's like okay cool here
is a sport that he's into and it's got
speed i've always loved sports with
speed and it's got rhythms which make
him happy and i realized what a better
way to bond with my child than to learn
how to stack myself i get to stand next
to my son who's one of the fastest in
the world
and stack with him and be a part of
something special
watching the two of them stack together
are probably some of the best moments
i've ever had our motto has always been
the family that stacks together stays
together
we go to these tournaments together
we've traveled together we've made
friends all over the country all over
the world i mean it's definitely
enriched our lives
you